new motivation was the top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to play big decide to be great and
keep the promises you made to you with
Ed my let and my take on his top 50
rules for success vol 2 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
1 play big look I feel like most people
in their lives are being allowed to live
small you're allowed to live a small
life everyone around you would like you
to live small just do this you're good
at that man take it easy chill when's
enough enough like come on brother you
know we're weak all these messes you get
is basically saying hey man live small
yeah life's not a big deal live small
enjoy it chill smoke a little weed do
whatever you want to walk right like
it's just this get by thing in life
there's got to be some people go no no
you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose
your way the way you were born the way
you were raised your background your
experiences your giftedness all prepared
you in your way for right now and you're
supposed to do something great with your
life you weren't born here to be average
and ordinary and there's all this
messaging that your average and ordinary
and your average annoyed because you
belong there and it's probably someone
else's fault your average and ordinary
to it I'm like no it's your life
you're in control it's no one else's
fault and you're supposed to do
something magnificent that's the
consciousness aspect the last thousand
years on earth doing something great has
been reserved to this one little group
of people one percent of the population
they're supposed to do something great
they're supposed to live their dreams
we're supposed to watch them cheer for
them
their Jersey watch their award show
comment on their posts clean their
houses right feed them in their
restaurants no the fact of the matter is
you can do those things you can change
your life and I'm sick and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big no if
you're a schoolteacher be the best damn
schoolteacher changed the world by those
little lives you're affected if you're
on social media change the role play big
you will never do it wrong if your
decisions to do the bigger thing than
the smaller thing that's what I would
tell you stop playing small stop
thinking small and don't let anybody
tell you you should be small
rule number two decide to be great see
in your life you're going to get what
you tolerate stop tolerating for these
people who have believed in you all your
life and inferior life for you stop
allowing God to bless you and give you
all this giftedness and opportunity and
settle and tolerate less for those
babies that are sitting there with you
your children and grandchildren stop
being willing to tolerate less for them
don't tolerate it anymore yeah you got
to give it your best but it starts
making a decision that this is over I
don't tolerate this life anymore
pretty Goods not good enough for my
family pretty Goods not good enough for
my grandmother
pretty Goods not good enough for my
grandpa my parents my future sure
pretty good ain't gonna get it done for
this family now I hope you hear them
whispering - he's right you can do this
you're great you're special you were
born for a reason I hope you can feel
that life's going to give you ultimately
what you'll fight for rule number three
keep the promises you make to you I've
been getting asked lately about the
struggles people are going through with
self-doubt not believing in themselves
negative thoughts about themselves and I
believe the solution to self-doubt is to
build something bigger than that doubt
which is to build our self-confidence
and one thing to know about the fact
that you doubt yourself is one I
struggle with it as well one of the
reasons I've had to go learn to build
all these tools for myself is because in
my life my baseball career my
career my business career my speaking
career I've been riddled with self-doubt
that creeps up all the time in our lives
am i enough am I good enough you weren't
born doubting you weren't born
discouraged you weren't born thinking
negative things about yourself
those were thoughts that were placed in
you and given to you by an external
source at some time in your life it
could even be our parents don't do that
be quiet sit down be a good boy
be a good girl maybe it was criticism
you received as a as a little one that
you may not even remember to this day
the process of building self-confidence
is actually very easy
believe it or not self-confidence is
self trust self confidence is building a
reputation with yourself that you keep
your word to you that you keep the
promises you make to you when I meet
somebody who has a ton of
self-confidence I don't look at that as
somebody with a big ego there's a
difference somebody with self-confidence
has a reputation with themselves and I
do the things I say I'm going to do
that's where self confidence comes from
when I meet someone who's not self
confident I know this is someone who has
consistently made promises to themselves
they've not kept they've started a diet
and done it for a while but not kept it
they've made a commitment and goals to
go make a certain amount of money in
business and they started down the road
but then they didn't deliver on it long
term to get up at a certain time of the
morning and then they don't do it and so
they have a process and a habit in their
life more often than not if not keeping
the promises they don't make to other
people they don't keep the promises I
make to themselves and so the cool thing
is self confidence is an internal game
you do not need external accolades
external admiration in order to build
self-confidence you don't need any of
those external forces it's all done
internally you control this and you
control this by beginning today to keep
the promises you make to yourself and
you have to stack the deck in your favor
stack the gain so you win it's not good
enough just to keep the promises you
make to yourself you must acknowledge it
when you do it to you to give yourself
credit to create confidence momentum is
what I call it so whether that's setting
the deck where you're gonna get up a
little bit earlier you're gonna make a
certain amount of phone calls you this
is a certain amount of appointments
you're gonna need a certain amount of
calories in your fitness you're gonna
certain amount of time with your
children or your parents and you begin
to do these things you say you're going
to be safe
simple things like I'm gonna lay out my
clothes the night before I go to bed
every night before I go to sleep so when
I wake up that decisions made for me and
believe it or not the fact that you just
do something that simple that you then
deliver on begins to build confidence
you say I'm gonna stretch in the morning
when I get up and you do it all of a
sudden I'm not gonna check my phone for
30 minutes all these habits I teach when
you just begin to do the things you tell
yourself you're going to do you begin to
build self-confidence which is this
reputation with yourself so ask yourself
a question right now what is one thing
right now one promise I can make to
myself that I'm going to begin to keep
starting this minute and begin to do it
a Kabhi Gham how often I'm gonna pick up
a book and read it but you begin to
stack things you commit to do and then
you deliver on them and you acknowledge
them to yourself you're in the process
of building self-confidence why is that
so important of all the athletes I coach
well my athletes are performing at their
peak level they're at their highest self
confidence level in fact I love when I
watched some of the athletes I coach get
interviewed and they kind of do this aw
shucks humble routine in their approach
game interviews yeah you know just part
of the team you know I got a lot I could
have done a lot better today but inside
I know these people are incredibly
self-confident people any of you
athletes listening this you know that's
the great athletes you know have
incredible amounts of self-confidence
you have to believe in you when it's a
battle when you're a hitter against a
pitcher or when you're a quarterback
against a defense or you're a defensive
in the NHL against their best offensive
player or you're a golfer and you have
to make a nine-foot putt to win a
tournament right you better help
self-confidence in fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is not they're a better
shooter or a better putter or throw the
ball a little bit faster because
everybody throws hard in the major
leagues nowadays it seems right that
separators their self-confidence it's
true and being a parent it's true and
being a businessperson it's true in
every year of our life the separator at
the top levels is self-confidence rule
number four collaborate I had to learn
to recruit and build the team I'm
literally a broke man financially if I
did not build eight
of people so I had to learn to motivate
and inspire and teach and all those
things and building a team this house is
built by that team my lake house built
by that team the Jets all those things
are built by the ten that I built yes
and so I learned early on and
collaborate so then when I went into the
personal development space I knew I had
to collaborate so I sought out the right
people to build that my support team
around me their audiences you know I do
their show they do my show posting etc
just like what we're doing right now and
so I believe everything in business
nowadays is team built there's a
misnomer that someone is self-made right
yeah there's all these people out there
that are working out of their homes
right now you cannot name a single
successful human being in the history of
mankind who didn't build a team Jesus
Christ built a team he built a team he
had his apostles for a reason that was
his frontline team and then they built
the team
there's nobody ever in life who has
built anything extraordinary with their
life alone ever period you must
collaborate you must build a team even
the greatest religious in the world
we're all built by teams of people so
clearly you in your living room right
now need to seed out some help some
teammates and some collaboration also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below the minute you begin
to get external in your life worrying
about what other people think about you
right you vote you've lost all control
you and it never fills you up rule
number five control your mind do you
ever think about what you think about
because if you did and if you took
control of that you could alter the
direction of your entire life most
people never take the time to take an
inventory about their thoughts yet our
thoughts control our world our thoughts
are like magnets they literally draw
towards us that's which we obsess about
and so most people never take the time
to analyze what they think about the
most successful people I know are the
most self-aware meaning they're aware of
what they do and they're also aware of
what they think they're aware of how
they're perceived average person you and
I have about seventy five thousand
thoughts a day rattling around in this
thing we call our brains in our mind
seventy five thousand of them the crazy
thing is 91% of those thoughts are
identical to the previous day and
identical to the day before that and the
day before that and the day before
for that and then we wonder why our life
seems to repeat itself over and over
again so really the difference in our
life if we have 75,000 thoughts a day
here's the crazy thing 91% of them are
exactly the same the separation our life
is in those nine percent of their
thoughts because we remember this these
magnets are pretty powerful that's why
I'm always saying that your obsessions
become your possessions because they do
you draw into your life exactly what it
is you think about it's a physical
reality that you attract to yourself
what you think about so the difference
in our life is 9% of our thoughts that's
why people say all the time the
difference between winning and losing is
so small it's almost too scary to talk
about and really we have identified what
it is it's 9% of what we think about
alters the direction of our life so what
I'm here to tell you today is you've got
to hone in and/or get aware of what you
think about and then alter those 9
percent of the thoughts that are
variable on a daily basis to serve you
rule number six invest belief in people
I should do it but the investment of
belief in people sowing seeds of belief
that's what makes you a leader people
say what makes me a leader makes you a
leader is your example what makes you a
leader is you investing belief and
loving and caring about people any one
of you in this moment to decide you're
gonna lead because leadership is
instilling something at someone but they
don't see in themselves love and autom
believe it I'm seeing their gifting as
all of you I don't care if you're loud
or quiet big here or small here you
could be a leader the bottom line is you
need to decide you want to lean rule
number seven transfer energy influence
is energy it's the transfer of energy
it's getting you to feel about my
company feel about my mission feel about
my product feel about my cause what I
feel they're conscious of transferring
energy to people because that's what
moves people that's what gets them to
act it's not just the words it's not
just your face it's not just how you're
dressed it's an energy transfer there's
a hook by the way you can't transfer to
me that what you're not experiencing
yourself you have to physically be
experiencing it in the moment it can't
just be the words you're reading from a
sheet you have to really believe it one
of the reasons a lot of salespeople
struggle or recruiters struggle is they
just don't
believe enough they don't spend enough
time making the case like a lawyer
litigating to themselves about how
powerful what they do is and the more
and more you really be very true
believer you can evangelize your product
you can evangelize your message so
invest more time in your own belief in
your research in your knowledge finding
third party articles magazines blogs
things that reinforce whatever it is
you're doing that feeds your own belief
that way you can give it to me you can't
give it to me if you don't have it rule
number eight turn difficulties into
triumphs so how many of you believe in
your life that your worst day can become
your best day if you turn it around I
happen to believe that that honestly the
old and a lot of books you read oh
there's a seed of every adversity
there's a seed of greatness you've all
heard that before right but it's
actually true if you were to go back in
your life some of the greatest trials
and tribulations difficulties you've
gone through I've ended up producing the
most beautiful things in your life is
that true yes rule number nine find
inspiration I was at the gym yesterday
and a woman drove by me in a wheelchair
at the gym I was working out pretty hard
and she wheeled by me heavyset lady in a
wheelchair I'd be honest with you I
watched her wheel past me she inspired
me do you know what courage it takes to
get in your wheelchair and decide I'm
gonna go to the gym right I'm gonna go
to the gym she's heavyset awkward that
inspired me far more than the jacked up
dude doing 60 pound curls I mean that's
inspiring but you see that a woman in a
wheelchair at a gym with her two pound
dumbbells because her legs don't work
but she went in there anyway and you
know how unsecure she was about going in
there she's the only person in a
wheelchair she doesn't know what she's
gonna see how people are gonna react to
her she's not in shape just never full
makeup on and her little you know halter
top like the other girls in there and
she's right in there she was right in
there working out right next to them
right I couldn't take my eyes off her I
couldn't take my eyes off her and I
ended up telling her this she was
leaving I left what I was doing I walked
over ice I just want you to know
something
you're inspiring me this is wonderful
her face just lit up because you know
how sad she how insecure she was about
being in there most inspiring person is
one overcoming the fear of doing
something not the person who's excellent
rule number ten find your true purpose I
had some heart cardiac issues so that's
when I started to think about my legacy
I don't need to be remembered that's for
some reason not been an important thing
to me that somehow like when I'm gone
that stuff's pretty overrated to me so I
do have two legacies the one is my
family and what I want to be able to do
for my children and I want them to live
a better life than I've lived and I want
us to make a difference in the world
it occurred to me the last five or ten
years though that like I was put on
earth for a reason there's a purpose to
my existence there's been a purpose to
my journey there's a purpose to my my in
my heart really wanting to help people
like I I love it there's I ended up at a
group home working in the beginning of
my business career and it changed my
life I was working with these boys they
were all orphans and all very young I
went oh that's my calling I want to help
and now God's given me this platform and
the ability to put words together pretty
well right and so I want to know that my
life was better for the world I feel
like the world today is so divided I
honestly believe that real people from
the grassroots I really believe
entrepreneurs social media influence
people's who have a voice in the world
today we can shift the consciousness of
the world I really believe that like and
so it's come to this point where like
the first half of my life was about
building something special for my own
family our own legacy and I've done that
the second half of my life as I want to
help contribute my part to changing the
world
I want my great-grandchildren to live in
a safer more collaborative more loving
world not just country I'm so passionate
about this bro I sleep very little
lately like I found my calling
yeah I found it and our voices all
combined those of you listening you and
I are louder than anyone politician are
louder than anyone countries are louder
than anyone little segmented you know
little group of people who are trying to
get their way in the world we can change
conscience we are the voice rule number
11 be hungry how bad do you want your
goal right now I think there's a lot of
people in the world today because it's
really nice thing to talk about I want
this this is my outcome this is my goal
like how bad you what you want as bad as
breathing do you want it as bad as
anything you ever wanted in your life
and if you
calibrate it at the highest enough
levels where I found the people that are
the hungriest they find a way when you
know why you want something when it's
desperation the power of being desperate
is something that most people avoid they
think desperation is a weakness and I'm
here to tell you desperation is one of
the most powerful emotions you could
possibly possess because when you're
desperate you find reserves and
reservoirs of ideas talents and a
strength that you don't know you have
when you find yourself in a desperate
situation so ironically the one thing
most people avoid in their life hunger
which is caused by being desperate when
you're starving
you become desperate think of somebody
who's starving on the street they've got
to how resourceful would you get if your
children were literally starving and you
had to feed them right so the number one
thing we need more than anything to win
is hunger which comes from a state of
desperation yet we're constantly trying
to comfort ourselves in the real world
to avoid the state of being desperate
and I'm telling you that I think you
need to embrace desperation again in
your life like do you want it so bad
that you're desperate for it see you in
a fight you show me to people this is
why it's so hard to repeat as a champion
in the fighting game because you show me
someone who's up and coming as hungry
for that title
who's never had it before who can taste
it who knows if they win that belt their
whole life's gonna change they're gonna
be champion of the world all the
endorsements all the money all their
family life all their parents lives are
gonna change you show me somebody
chasing that hungry for it against some
of those just trying to hold on to a
title and that's why most of the time
the challenger beats the champ it's hard
to repeat as a champion because the
hunger goes down just a little bit the
greatest athletes the Kobe's the Bradys
the Jordans of sports have a way of
feeding their hunger all the time and
increasing it what separates them isn't
just their work ethic isn't just their
talent although those things matter
isn't just they practice more what
separates them as they're just hungrier
they somehow find a way as they climb up
the ranks and win championship to get
even hungrier for more where 99% of the
athletes lose just a
little bit of their edge once they get
that first championship that first pro
contract that first big amount of money
that first world championship they just
lose their hunger a little bit and then
there's the elite they get hungrier it
feeds the beast rule number 12
take responsibility no one's gonna do
anything for you couple rules of being a
real leader you need to take
responsibility for your own life bring
an energy to your team leading and
recruiting leading in leadership leading
in growth nobody owes you anything but
you owe other people
everything that's what a leader does you
take responsibility you know exactly
right now what you're not doing it would
be criminal of you to leave here and say
I don't know what to do you know exactly
what you're afraid of you know exactly
what you've been avoiding and you got to
make a decision to change it you know
exactly what it is don't BS anybody you
know what you need to do different you
know the changes you need to make and if
you could do that and stop kidding
yourself you can win you can overcome
your fear overcome procrastination
whatever that is rule number 13 change
your patterns you are not your
possessions you are not your
accomplishments you are not what other
people say you are you are not what you
look like and guess what else you're not
you are not your patterns but your life
becomes a combination and a result of
your patterns the great thing about us
is that we can change these patterns if
we identify them the pattern has no
power over you once you know it's a
program and a pattern running the minute
you start you go Mike I'm doing it again
aren't I I'm doing this thing I do every
time I accumulate money I'm doing the
same thing every time me and my spouse
get in a disagreement I'm doing the same
thing every time I'm starting to feel
loved by somebody and I push them away
every time things start to go bad
financially I spiral every time there's
adversity I do the same pattern where I
start worrying every time I get fit I do
the same pattern when you begin to see
these things you begin oh my gosh this
isn't Who I am
that's not your identity there's a
difference between your identity and
your pattern and the more you begin to
build your identity as I've talked about
my other audios and be aware of patterns
and then simply ask yourself when this
comes up again in the future what
would serve me what pattern can I take
control of what would be the steps I
need to take that will create the Bliss
I want or the win I want or the
production I want what would the pattern
need to be rule number fourteen be
decisive you've got to start to build a
habit of being decisive successful
people happy people leaders are decisive
people and I believe somewhere if
there's a hundred problems challenges in
life 85 of them should be decided
immediately with not a lot of
deliberation and then certainty and
massive action will eliminate that
challenge of that problem most of the
time it's the people who procrastinate
on the problem or ignore it or think it
might go away that gives that problem
time to magnify to fester to grow to
where now it's become bigger than it
needed to be
rule number 15 believe lack of belief
it'll steal your dream you got to know
you're gonna win you gotta have some
faith these people sitting around you
right now they're whispering to you you
could do this I believe it just like
when you were a little boy just like
when you were a little girl
they've always believed in you they've
always known you're gonna do something
special they always knew you were great
you need to know it you need to take
that god that's sitting there with you
and those precious souls that have
passed that I've always believed in you
and you carry them with you everywhere
they're with you anyway acknowledge them
if you don't believe that honor them
honor God honor these people who
believed in you with your magnificent
life honor them don't give in to lack of
belief lack of confidence don't ever do
that again
don't do it NW fgr out of wfg you were
made to do something great you're
special you're made the image of God
something awesome supposed to happen for
you and those of you that have made
something that awesome happened
something even more awesome supposed to
happen for you rule number 16 don't
compare yourself to others don't compare
yourself most of the people you see on
social media or even in your personal
life or even when you go to lunch with
them or see them at work they're wearing
what I would call a public mask it's the
best possible version that they can put
out to themselves and oftentimes what we
do in life is we compare our real
identity that we're working
and we're growing to their mask and
that's not fair to ourselves at all any
comparison doesn't serve us and it's
oftentimes this comparison when you're
in a disagreement with somebody it's the
mask they're wearing compared to the
identity you have and then you begin to
run a pattern to respond to it
it happens in in Fitness in
relationships in money and in business
remember you're in charge of controlling
your own identity and growing your own
identity and being aware of the patterns
you have that do and do not serve you
not comparing yourself to someone else
as public representative it's just the
representative they're putting out there
it's not who they really are
and it's not something that you need to
be aware of because it's not something
you can control
the more you can begin to delineate in
life between things I can control and I
cannot control would be to the extent
that you're more productive and you're
happier you can control your own
thoughts your own emotions your own
identity and your own patterns not other
people's rule number 17 get laser
focused human beings that get obsessed
and immersed in any topic to become
great at it and so can you so pick what
you want and get laser focused begin to
eliminate all the distractions you are
not hungry enough you are not starving
enough and you are not focused enough I
say this to you as a friend what are the
things that are stealing your focus who
are the people that are stealing your
focus and begin to eliminate these
distractions get laser focus and
obsessed on what you want be starving
and hungry to get it be desperate to get
it the combination of desperation and
hunger with laser focus over an extended
period of time is the formula to be
great at something and you can apply
this formula get laser focused eliminate
distractions eliminate the things that
steal your laser focused on it your
research on it your obsession on it
begin to do these things and you will
begin to change your entire life
rule number 18 master communication what
is uh probably the most important thing
to me in my life as I think that my
children think that their daddy helps
people and what they've learned from me
both of them as massive work ethic both
my kids are super hard-working good
people
all I want them to have when they leave
my house is I want them to have my work
ethic and I want them to have their
faith and I want them to have
self-confidence and I want them to be
able to communicate I think if you can
leave the family with those things work
ethic faith self-confidence and the
ability to communicate you're probably
gonna have a pretty good life it takes
care of every area your face gonna make
sure you're a good person and you
contribute and you do well and you've
got morals your self-confidence is
obvious work ethic is obvious but the
underestimated thing in life is the
ability to communicate your thoughts and
your ideas and the world today
information is a dime a dozen if you're
going to succeed in this life you have
to be able to communicate how you're
feeling and thinking and transfer
information to people and I want them to
be good at that too those are the things
I always think of with my kids
rule number 19 focused on a solution not
a problem problems need energy to live I
want you to own that remember this
problems need energy to live and so the
concept should be that we solve problems
but we don't have to pour and deplete
ourselves of energy because the more
energy you give something the more it
expands we want to be in the max out
universe we want to pour our energy and
expense our energy towards the solution
not towards the problem so the first
thing I want you to write down is 90% of
your energy focused time and thought
should be towards the solution not
towards the problem itself this is a
mistake most people make because they
expend all the energy into the problem
they obsess over the problem the problem
and when you expand energy it grows to
survive and the problem gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and the
solution becomes more and more difficult
so the first thing is can you
consciously begin to focus on energy
expansion into the solution 90% of it
into the solution and not into the
problem what we do is we repeat that
problem over and over and over again and
we magnify it to the point where we
don't come up with realistic solutions
and we deplete ourselves as energy
towards the solution and so focus going
forward when a problem arises and
challenge arises that you focus 90% of
your energy and
on the solution and not repeating the
problem to yourself rule number 20 seek
more bliss assuming you want more bliss
in your life decide to have it and take
some actions towards getting it so let
me ask you a question
what are you doing currently to create
more bliss in your life what are the
actions you're taking to give yourself
more bliss you were intentionally
seeking more bliss because bliss is
gonna lead to more wealth more abundance
more fitness more faith better
relationships more happiness more peace
more winds more success more recognition
more significance so what are you
consciously doing now that you've chosen
bliss what is the consistent action
you're taking to create more in your
life what are you doing to give yourself
bliss rule number 21 sell the dream see
great leaders always sell the dream
leaders must have vision because of your
position just by being a position of a
leader you are in front of everybody
aren't you which means your point of
view should be different you can see
things they can't see your job as a
leaders to say here's what I see this is
how amazing it is and this is how we're
going to get there so great leaders like
that book said sell the dream constantly
great entrepreneur constantly conscious
of selling the dream to their employees
to their clients to their vendors to
potential clients to people they sell to
people they do business with two people
in the warehouse no matter what your
business is I don't care what it is
always be selling the dream listen to me
always be selling the dream and do it
repetitiously don't get tired of saying
the same things over and over again see
business is not about saying new things
to old people business about saying old
things to new people so constantly be
selling a dream rule number 22 be
relentless people quittin chargebacks
flunking the exam that's all gonna
happen just get ready if you're an
entrepreneur and you want to do
something great
you're gonna have false start after
false start false start after false talk
get it go and then you don't get it
going then you dump your group grows
then it shrinks I'm telling you right
now just know that I'm gonna make some
money then you're not being an
entrepreneur tons of false starts tons
of setbacks but the
guy like me I knew someone was better
than me there's more talented people
than me probably more talented than you
but like my dad said the best ability is
availability you might outwork me for 30
days or 60 days or 90 days but you ain't
gonna beat me over a year
you can outwork me over two years you
are gonna outwork me over three years
i'ma get you eventually I'm a dripping
dam faucet I just keep coming at you
just like you could be right just like
you can I just keep coming you might
think I'm knocked out I just keep coming
I'm too damn tough to give up
most people half-ass half their life all
the time
I knew they're gonna get tired they were
gonna flinch they were to get down they
may not quit the match to the letter
resume quit getting why'd they quit
recruiting people they quit and proven
themselves they start sleeping in they
spend all their damn money I'm not gonna
do that so I'm gonna save money but get
up early I'm gonna keep getting wide I'm
gonna stay relentless just like you
should don't give in to that stuff don't
give in to the fears don't give in to
the setbacks you're gonna have failure
it's part of the game
rule number 23 get laser-focused one of
the things that human beings
underestimate dramatically is their
capacity to get great at something if
they're totally immersed in it totally
laser focused on something but as I've
coached the very high-end athletes in my
life the top businesspeople and
entertainers I can tell you that most
people underestimate what total
obsessive laser-focused really is and
what it looks like because you are way
more powerful than you know you are if
you went crazy psycho obsessed laser
focused on anything even something
you're totally ill-prepared for humans
have an unreal capacity to get great at
things even if they're not a natural
talent for it if they're immersed in it
and to learn something and acquire a ton
of knowledge in a short period of time
as well society is conspiring all the
time in our culture to completely
distract you so you never win to just
divert your focus and attention look
over here look at this shiny thing look
at this TV show look at this sports team
worried about what's going on here in
this war and they
these different things on television and
our phones and in our lives and just get
us distracted so we never get obsessed
we never get laser focused for an
extended period of time rule number 24
choose the life you want you get to
choose your life you get to choose how
you feel not other people there's these
illusions in life we really can't
control anything other than our own
thoughts our own behavior our own
patterns we can't control what other
people do say or think
and it's this illusion of control often
times that we can somehow manipulate
other people or manipulate situations
that cause us to fall into these
patterns but what we do have the power
of in life as we have the power to
choose and I say this to you because I'm
somebody just like you I struggle with
the different patterns I have some of
them serve me some of them don't
I sometimes engage in thoughts that
don't create the right emotions for me
that don't serve me I know what it's
like to be frustrated and angry and
depressed and down and lost and fearful
and worried worries a big one for me I
love to fall into the pattern of worry
with certain circumstances begin to
happen it creates a trigger and a
pattern in me and man do I love to worry
and so I give you these tools and
resources because these are things I too
struggle with I've been able to overcome
them by just being aware and choosing
and so the first thing is the power of
choice finish this sentence for me I
choose to be blissful rather than blank
I choose to be blissful rather than
blank what would your answer be one of
the emotions I challenge you to
experience more of in life is bliss you
know we are the calibration of maybe the
five emotions we experience on a regular
basis and so if you're experiencing
depression frustration worry fear
anxiety pain on a regular basis you're
gonna have one life they're experiencing
bliss and fulfillment and ecstasy and
joy and in your life and contribution
recognition and significance if you're
experiencing love experience those
emotions you have a totally different
life we have the power to choose which
emotions we want to experience rule
number 25 leverage problems to
there's nothing wrong with making
mistakes there's nothing wrong with even
having problems there's a challenge if
we continue to repeat the same mistake
that causes the same problems and so
what can I learn from this
now you're leveraging this problem to
grow now this isn't something you're
just overcoming and putting behind you
but you're using this experience in this
challenge to move in front of it not
just get it behind you there's a big
difference in that perspective what's
great about this problem that's a
difficult question to ask when you're
going through the middle of it ed no
it's not not if you build the habit not
if you begin to think like this because
what that does is it changes the meaning
to you it puts you in an empowering
state and not a disempowering state rule
number 26 get hungry and obsessed you've
got to get hungry and you've got to get
focused and I know they sound like basic
things but go to any area of your life
you want something right now pick the
number one thing you want to change body
money business relationship faith I
don't care what it is pick it right now
1 to 10 how hungry are you how desperate
are you 1 to 10 the most desperate and
hungry you could be ranked yourself
number two how lazor crazy obsessed
focused are you on what it is you want 1
to 10 10 being hyper psycho crazy
obsessed focus
nothing's in your way and to the extent
you can increase your desperation and
hunger and your obsessive focus will be
to the extent that you can flourish
because when those things convene and
converge all of a sudden the
collaborations the people the
circumstances the breakthroughs the
insights necessary begin to reveal
themselves to you and not only that
reveal themselves to you with momentum
and speed at which you cannot believe
you can wake up a year and a half later
be number one in the world it's
something that you didn't even know
existed before I'm a testimony to that
and you can be as well your success is
going to be predicated more than
anything on your hunger and desperation
level and your ability to get laser
focus and eliminate the distractions in
your life this is what makes us great
rule number 27 recognize others always
be recognizing people always be holding
people up always acknowledge people that
are performing
high level build an environment where
you're recognizing people all the time
so that people want to rise up you know
if you have an environment of
recognition all the time that the people
who aren't being recognized see the ones
who are and want that to happen so
recognition elevates the company
elevates your vendors elevates your
clients by the way what do you do to
recognize your clients what do you do in
your business to recognize your clients
what do you do to recognize your
recruits what do you do to recognize
your employees we need to recognize your
vendors what do you do to recognize your
assistant what do you do to recognize
people how great are you at recognizing
people rule number 28 learn to listen
and one of the things we've not covered
that is such a critical part of
communication and maybe more important
even what you say is your ability to
listen to people it's a huge part of
communication you know I've taught you
before that people don't respond to what
they hear or see they respond to how
they feel when they interact with you
and one of the best ways to make
somebody feel good is that they feel
listened to and that they feel heard I
think being a great listener has lots of
benefits one people will like you more -
you're going to learn more three it
takes the pressure off you and so
listening skills are so critical
rule number 29 believe in your worth
whatever it is good bad or indifferent
in your life your current level of
happiness of joy of success of
fulfillment is exactly what you think
you deserve it's exactly what you think
you're worth it's a hard thing to accept
but in our lives we are getting out of
our life right now exactly what we
believe we're worthy of exactly what we
think we deserve our life is a direct
reflection of our identity which is the
thoughts concepts beliefs values and
worth we hold true to be about ourselves
and so as hard as it is to accept we're
getting out of life right now what we
believe were worth and we believe we're
worth it because of these patterns and
our identity and our lack of choosing to
have what we want not just the material
things not just the body fat not just
the body weight not just the amount of
money not just having the relationship
but choosing the emotion we want rule
number 30 tell great stories
my dad's a tough dude that was a hockey
player
when I was a little boy I was little
Eddie I'm Eddie the third by the way my
grandfather's Edward my dad's Edward I'm
Everett so I was little Eddie Eddie the
third kids at school called me Eddie
spaghetti that wasn't fun say Eddie
spaghetti your meatballs are ready
that's they would say that's how they'd
tease me and the the jerk that started
this lived right next door to me little
ray-ray this little punk
so there's little Eddie in there's
ray-ray
why is he Ray Ray because his dad's big
Greg we lived in Weymouth Massachusetts
at the time there one but they wouldn't
want to retire there let's put it that
way
that is not Laguna Beach is it everybody
so my house my house is the same exact
house is Ray race Jeff do you know I
track houses I just flip them so is his
house my house in Reverse so we shared a
driveway their porch their stairs to
their house was here mine was there so
when they're eating dinner I can hear
all their conversations they could hear
all us and Ray Ray's the one who started
Eddie spaghetti your meatballs are ready
and I didn't like it
it needs to kind of mess with me he's
figured out I was kind of soft you know
you kind of figure it out like we're
playing football on the street he kind
of whacked me I wouldn't walk him back
you know those kind of things little
kids do to figure it out
he was the stud I was the weak kid and
he figured it out he was big I was
little Eddie literally little Eddie
really small and so rare I used to kind
of slap me around a little bit and one
day we got a little scrape behind the
cars from the driveway and Ray Ray
kicked my ass pretty good pretty damn
good to the point where I ran away from
him crying maybe you can relate to this
and I ran into the house and my mom was
on push oh my gosh come here sweetheart
I remember come here baby we're in the
kitchen and she's hugging me it's okay
he's a bad boy his daddy's been in jail
like three times and I can hear I can
hear here comes big head down the
hallway I can hear him I'm thinking he's
gonna give me a big hug to write my digs
what the hell's going on in here okay my
mom turns around and says this criminal
next door
ray ray has assaulted our son for the
400th time that's what's going on here
are you gonna do anything about this and
my dad goes get your hands off him
because get over here and he gets down
at my level he goes look at me
you are leaving this house and you were
going back over there and you were
kicking his ass you understand me dad I
said you don't come back in this house
until you kick his ass you understand me
my mom and what are you doing Debbie
stop it I know what I'm doing here
don't come back here until you beat him
up you understand me oh okay daddy and I
walk out of the door and I walk over to
their porch which is like three steps
from us and my dad took behind the
screen I see him in the kitchen behind
our screen with my mom my mom's crying
my dad's like I got this right and I
knock on the door their screen that big
ray all tatted up no shirt on he's
through the street what's up Eddie he
said um big ray my dad says I have to
come over here and kick ray Ray's ass or
I can't come home for dinner
so and be ready girls I like that kind
of party let's get it I'm serious I hear
I'm at the door right right right right
that's all yeah right right
get over here little rain little Bulldog
comes running up right
he goes hey Bill Eddie wants another
piece rayray goes let's do this I'm like
home and we're walking down his stairs
and I could see my dad in the screen
over here oh my god oh my god
and I'll never forget this the two cars
are they're my dad's Datsun b210 orange
hash back in his dad's green pink toe
flanked our states right there in the
driveway oil all over the driveway cuz
big ray would change everything in the
driveway and we got up there and big ray
goes you get there you get there go and
Ray Ray came at me and buy some force of
cheer blessing from God I got this
little dude in a headlock and I'm giving
him my daddy's to give me noogies
remember Nikki's slightly not to hit him
but I'm looking the hell out of his
kid's head just nice I'm ripping the
hair off his damn head and I'm choking
them cookies I'm trying to looking back
to the screen see my dad my god and dad
I got him dad and so finally I'm moving
in this kid to death literally can't
breathe and so finally raised Oh get
away get away I'm here get him right
Mike I won't let him go he's trying to
squirm and I'm gonna slap with him in a
head these little boys out there right
and so finally I'll kick his ass right
now
so big race tops it'd be ray pulls us
off each other to go see ray ready he
got you let's shake his hand then we
shook hands and I walked home my dad's
night now get in here let's make some
spaghetti let's do this right right so
proud of me so now now it's gonna tell
you a couple of things you know number
one that top made life will give you
what you'll fight for that's really the
point of the story now my mother who
heard me tell the story one of the times
she feels like I should also divulge
another set of facts I don't even know
why this is relevant at all
but because my mom asks you I will just
because this was the I just tell you I
was seven Ray Ray was four I just want
you to know that but I don't know why
that's even relevant why is that
relevant
for real
that's true little seven-year-old
kicking a four-year-old's but with
noogies in the driveway but hey listen
to me you all got some RayRay's in your
life stuff you make much bigger and more
difficult and more powerful than it is
that could defeat you in hindsight I was
damn seven years old this kid was
practically in diapers still of course I
could kick his butt right so hey maybe
you can relate to that you got something
you like like that alright mom you see
this on YouTube I did tell the truth
this time so just so you know
rule number 31 max out see I accepted a
long time ago I wasn't the smartest the
best-looking the fast enough with the
best background the most connections I
don't have any of those things what I
could control was my work ethic you've
heard me speak many times about out
working everybody but I think that just
feels good when we hear it but most
people don't take it seriously if you
think that I have a little bit of
success in my life I can tell you what I
attribute it to
yes self-confidence yes mindset
visualization goals all the things I
talk about all the time listening skills
influence energy transfer how to be
happier all of that stuff applies when
you get to winning for me it's come down
to maxing out and what maxing out means
is you do one more at least than you
think you're capable of so when you're
done whatever you're doing whether it's
at the gym or phone calls or meetings or
in sports one more shot one more throw
one more swing of the golf club or the
baseball bat the separator is for the
winners they do one more I'm addicted to
one more and so I want your mantra going
forward to be one more rule number 30 to
help others win what are you doing to
intentionally create bliss in the lives
of the people that you care about
because this is the pathway to getting
more of it ourselves the more we begin
to give other people bliss the more
we're being to consciously make choices
that give bliss to other people in their
lives the more we begin to experience an
abundance ourselves so what are you
doing to help other people win other
people contribute other people get
significance and recognition other
people have more peace
and ecstasy and joy and passion in their
lives because once you begin to create
it for other people when you're
intentional about it you'll have more of
it yourself these are the patterns that
I'd like to see kick in for you that
when they kick in you begin to run a
pattern in a program that leads you to
bliss lead you to a win lead you to
increase and also leads to it with
someone in your life that if you do have
a conflict with somebody that you run a
pattern that eventually leads maybe it's
understanding that maybe it's
confronting them maybe it's talking
about it it's not always when you're in
a disagreement that you lead to a win
that you must win this that you must
overcome the fact that they think this
of you what if you are consciously
choosing every time you got into a
disagreement with your spouse this will
eventually lead to more bliss at least
that was your outcome now the steps you
take it's probably gonna be ugly in the
beginning you're probably gonna have to
some understanding you may not even
agree on everything but if your
intention is that it leads to bliss
rather than you winning rather than you
controlling them
rather than you making it go away rather
than you running a pattern if when
you're beginning to succeed in business
if your outcome is more bliss more
winning you'll run a pattern that does
more of that rule number 33 chase your
dreams you know squirrels can't find 74%
of the nuts they hide what a fun factor
what why is that matter because you've
been burying your dreams all your damn
life and guess what
you can't think you're waiting for the
right time when winter comes you go find
your little acorns right you think
you're gonna find them let me tell you
something you keep burying those dreams
the longer you wait the harder they are
to find it's time you dig those things
out right now and find them and put them
right in front of you again and go chase
them you can have a great family and a
great business and a great financial
situation and feel great about yourself
and travel the world and do whatever the
heck it is you want but you need to dig
those dreams out right now
rule number 34 believing your worth you
know what you allow is what's going to
continue in your life I put out a post
about this several weeks ago it's hard
to accept this but what's happening in
our lives we're allowing it to happen
and to some extent we almost believe we
deserve it because we produce in our
life what we really believe we're worth
what we really believe we deserve and
doesn't it's hard to accept that because
it seems coincidental you know that the
wrong person or life or there was a
business setback or our car broke down
or you know our company went out of
business or whatever it might be one of
your clients just quit and change their
mind and it seems coincidental but you
really truly are getting out of your
life would you believe your worth what
you believe you deserve and you're
allowing it to happen and I'm gonna
challenge you today to stop that stop
allowing it and know that you deserve
better
rule number 35 create raving fans great
businesses those are their business
people great businesses have a cult-like
following have a religious like
following it's something that all great
movements out apple has it the great
fitness companies that you think of any
company you know that's really
flourishing has kind of raving fans and
a level past that is almost cult-like
and religious like followers they
believe that deeply my by the way I
don't mean that in a sacrilegious way
like they believe in it more than they
believe in God you know exactly what I
mean when I say that deep raving fans
and those followings are led by
evangelist all great businesspeople
I think all great dads all great moms
should be evangelical about their family
all great business leader should be
evangelist constantly touting the
greatness of your family the greatness
of where you're going the greatness of
your company rule number 36 be different
are you willing to do the ugly by the
way do you know what the ugly is right
the ugly is doing all the stuff the
people who lose aren't willing to do you
got to make those phone calls you got to
see people you're gonna have to put up
with some rejection you got to put
yourself in an uncomfortable place
listen to me do it
put yourself in an uncomfortable place
don't negotiate it don't try to navigate
it in your head
negotiation you will lose okay
unrealistic people rule the world quit
trying to be so dadgum realistic okay
remember this weird rich normal poor can
you remember that say yes get a little
goofy look at Cardone he's a complete
whack job just so you know
rule number 37 take massive action and
then most people don't understand you
can obliterate most problems with just
massive
action I see people hem and haw and make
excuses all the time when challenges
arise and it would have just been solved
if you two decided you'd have been
totally certain and you don't litter
eight that problem with some massive
action rule number 38 stopped comparing
I want you to remember something
comparison is the pathway to unhappiness
I'm telling you that in every area of
your life where you find unhappiness you
will find comparison in fact the
antithesis to that is also true when
there is no comparison you cannot create
unhappiness in your life that's a pretty
bold and powerful statement but it's
true we only feel unhappy in our lives
when we compare something to maybe
something in our life that was a
different time maybe perhaps when we
were wealthier or in a different
relationship where we were healthier in
some level comparing our current
conditions to previous ones that
comparison is what creates the
unhappiness that's actually not the
condition itself or perhaps you're in a
relationship where you compare it to a
previous relationship you had and how
they treat it or how you felt at that
time perhaps you compare this time in
your life just to us simply a different
time and that comparison will always
create unhappiness in your life if you
can remove yourself from comparing both
yourself to a previous time in your life
a previous condition a previous
situation or even comparing yourself to
other people in your life this is a
recipe and a formula for unhappiness
every single time in your life where
you're experiencing unhappiness you are
doing a comparison to something
it's the contradiction between your
current situation current relationship
current body current finances
current anything and something exterior
either a previous time in your life a
previous person your life or are you
comparing yours to someone else's it is
an insidious disease that so many people
in society suffer from today
particularly because of the advent of
social media we watched someone's video
of what they're doing on a Friday night
and it's not what they're doing that
makes us unhappy it's comparing what
they're doing to what we're doing that
makes us unhappy rule number 39 play
offense the people in life listen to me
the people in life that win play offense
not defense stop backing into everything
stand up bow your back a little
start to walk a little different start
to be that best version of you you could
do it in your quiet way you can do it
the way you do it but somehow they got a
look at you ago okay I want monkey with
that one okay you read a competitor you
recruit them you can fail you go get
another recruit rule number forty be
clear on your goals
ask yourself truthfully your big goals
and dreams are you really clear on what
they are because if you don't have that
we can't even get started but assuming
you've listened to all of my previous
content before you know how mandatory it
is to be clear and specific for what you
want right but then the next layer is
this can you get laser obsessively
focused almost to its exclusivity almost
but for an extended period of time can
you honestly say you've done that for an
extended period about a year two years
three years four years five years even a
decade towards something you want so
badly you want it like oxygens like you
want it like you want to eat you want it
like you want to live right well are you
extended ly laser focused on it or do
you get distracted easily
rule number forty-one out work everyone
I'm addicted to one more and so I want
your mantra going forward to be one more
what does that look like if we're
working out that means when we're in the
gym and we say I'm gonna do five sets of
ten I'm crazy like I'm a psycho cuz I
want to win I want to be somebody I want
to separate I want to compete and the
way I do that isn't with my giftedness
because I wasn't born with a bunch of
gifts and I think gifts are crap I think
for the most part gifted people struggle
in life because things come easy them I
like the things haven't come easy for me
in my life I like to have natural
talents in every area and maybe you like
that about you too maybe you've looked
at yourself all your life and thought
man I don't have that natural beauty or
that natural talent or this gift for
creativity or intellect or humor I don't
have any of those things but what I got
is I will outwork you and so at the gym
one of the things I focus on they say
it's five sets of ten when I'm at ten I
go one
BAM eleven if I'm running on the
treadmill and it's a 45-minute run I
never finish at forty five always go one
more minute forty six if I'm at the
office and I'm supposed to make 25 phone
calls that day when I'm at the end of
the day I always do one more if I've got
meetings I always do one more
my mantra for three decades in business
has been one more rule number 42 get
obsessed let's talk first of all about
getting laser focus and I mean this is
your friend
I mean it's talking to myself - I always
cover things that make me better things
that I struggle with but I gotta tell
you I think there's a different level
for you I mean I think there's a
different level for you to get obsessed
crazy laser focus I say all the time our
obsessions become our possessions but we
won't possess them if we're not truly
obsessed I bet there's been a person in
your life you've been obsessed with if
you're over 20 years old listen to this
more than likely you've had somebody you
were pretty obsessed with haven't you
that you wanted in your life you wanted
to date you wanted as a girlfriend or a
boyfriend or a significant other how
many times a day do you think about them
how many times a day did they distract
you from what you were doing with just
the thought of them in other words this
is what I want you understand when
you're Laser obsessed focused your
obsession distracts you from what you're
currently doing not the other way around
you're not really obsessed with it if
you're easily distracted from it this is
so important you right now can test
whether it's your obsession with whether
it distracts you constantly the first
thing you think of when you wake up last
thing before you go to bed when you have
a big laugh it comes up when you cry it
comes up when you're watching TV it
comes up when you're doing your regular
job but it's your side hustle it comes
up you can't stop thinking about it it
distracts you from the rest of your life
that's what an obsession does when it's
not really your obsession the rest of
your life distracts you from it and so
that it in your life is so important but
there's all these things that distract
us today I'm gonna give you a
recommendation turn your damn TV off
turn the radio off most of the time turn
your phone off a lot too rule number 43
take action you got to rise up you got
to make your dreams a reality and live a
day
masterpiece you know this now here's the
thing couple things you got to make a
decision
listen to me you got to make a decision
what's the decision what's the thing you
came here for now we're at the moment
the clock is ticking people say all the
time hey life is short let me tell you
something
life can be long you bury your dreams
you quit this life gets long see times
relative two minutes of you being with
your sweetie doing whatever you'd like
to do with them that can go by quick
right what about the last two minutes on
a treadmill does that not seem like it
goes by for like four hours right so if
you're enjoying it it's short if it's
painful it's long life can be long you
want a life that feels like it's flying
by you want a life like I have right now
where I go can I just press pause okay I
just press pause it's so good it's so
great it's so rewarding it's so awesome
but I don't want any want to press pause
because I know it can get better
so what's the decision what have you
been sitting on what is it is it people
are texting me hey and I submitted my
resignation last night I'm coming
full-time I walked away from a
six-figure job is that the decision is
that the decision to finally get serious
is the decision to get license is the
decision to stop worrying about what
people think is the decision to become a
great closer
it's the decision something in a
relationship you have you need to get
out or in two it's only a thought if you
don't take an action the difference
between a thought and a decision is an
action so we know and you know you just
decided and you know what it is you know
what it is you will have really decided
if within this next hour you took some
step towards it something a note you
write a text you send a decision you've
made something you do that you follow up
with the action to make it real
rule number 44 stop the comparison game
it's not the success of people you know
that's making you unhappy it's you're
comparing your situation to the success
they're having that creates unhappiness
in your life so for those of you that
are struggling and saying you know one
of the things I suffer from is I'm just
not very happy very often I can tell you
that that pres
of unhappiness you will always link to a
comparison of some sort either in your
own life or in other people's lives and
just being aware of that fact and
stopping the comparison embracing this
moment embracing this time knowing that
you can't go back to that previous time
knowing that you can't be in somebody
else's life you're not gonna have that
other body right now and so if you're
looking to be happier I can promise you
the number one key that I would give you
is to stop the comparison game you say
well that's not completely true I mean
what if someone passes away that makes
me unhappy there's no comparison there
let's take the most extreme example or
when someone's sick in my family you
know there's someone in my family's got
a really bad illness that makes me
unhappy that's not a comparison in fact
it is the fact of the matter is that
when someone gets sick and your family
or passes away what you do in your mind
is you compare it to when they were
healthy so that comparison of I wish
they were healthier again that is a
comparison between the previous
situation and the current condition if
someone passes away it's comparing the
time that you had them that's why people
say if I could just have one more moment
with them if I could just have another
conversation it's comparing it to when
you had the moment it's comparing it to
when you had the conversation and so
those are extreme examples but if we
reduce it all the way down to anything
right now in your life that you say it
brings me unhappiness there's no joy
there there's a comparison happening
that's not serving you
rule number 45 alter your daily choices
the power of choice is critical in our
lives I want you to think about
something right now
what are five of the most important
choices you've made in your life just
think about that for a second begin to
list them off in your head five of the
most important choices you've made in
your life
maybe it was a decision to get involved
in a particular business or to leave a
particular business maybe it was a
decision to get involved with a
particular person or to become
uninvolved with a particular person
maybe it was a friend but you chose to
walk across the room and meet and it
changed your life maybe it was a friend
that you had to walk away from in order
to improve your life what are the five
most important choices of your life
just think about them for a second and
if you altered those five choices good
bad or indifferent how different would
your life be today because I'm a
believer that there's everyday choices
we make that when you stack them up they
make a massive difference in our life
but I'm also believer that there are
between five and ten a handful of
moments in everybody's life that if we
make the proper choices in those moments
the complete trajectory of our life
changes and I think as you just asked
yourself that question you may say there
haven't been five there's been two what
were they and how they alter the
direction of your life rule number 46
look back 60 to 90 days when I'm having
a difficult time in my life in one area
another all I have to really do is look
back 60 to 90 days and it's the
behaviors I had 60 to 90 days ago that
are causing the results I get negatively
right now and so like for example when
I'm not really you know progressing in
my career or in my financial situation
if I look back 60 to 90 days prior I
stopped reading the books listening to
the audios doing the things that grow my
identity and I pay the price 60 to 90
days later in my body my body isn't
looking like I want it to if I look back
60 to 90 120 days that's what my diet
got weaker that's when my workouts
weren't quite as intense as they were
previously and I pay the price three to
four months later this is true in every
area of our life our lives are almost
like reading a newspaper today but we're
reading the headlines for 90 days ago
and so that's what confuses people they
see the external results of their life
but if you did if you read the newspaper
from ninety two hundred and twenty days
ago that's where the news was made not
today and so in every area of your life
you got it going right now you've got a
fuel to fire if you've got your business
going your finances going your
relationship going your faith going
where you want it to you have to
continue to do the activities that got
you here in the first place because 90
days from now you're gonna read today's
news that's how it works
rule number 47 choose the life you want
it's a hard thing to accept
but in our lives we are getting out of
our life right now exactly what we
believe we're worthy of
exactly what we think we deserve our
life is a direct reflection of our
identity which is the thoughts concepts
beliefs values and worth we hold true to
be about ourselves and so as hard as it
is to accept we're getting out of life
right now what we believe we're worth
and we believe we're worth it because of
these patterns and our identity and our
lack of choosing to have what we want
not just the material things not just
the body fat not just the body weight
not just the amount of money not just
having the relationship but choosing the
emotion we want the level above all this
stuff I discuss and the level way down
here were the people discover the basic
stuff then there's what I've been
covering the highest level is to choose
the emotions we want to experience and
to begin to run patterns that serve us
and eliminate the ones who move us
further from them
rule number 48 write your own story I
want you to think about something real
quick see there's a book being written
about your life isn't there someone
somewheres take an inventory of your
life don't compare your chapter 1 -
someone's chapter 10 you write your own
book and at any moment in your life you
can decide that you want to make this
the new chapter you're literally in your
life you can turn the page in those
previous chapters or your old book it's
like Old Testament New Testament old
story new story they're connected
they're related but you can flip the
page and you can have a whole new story
if you decided right now I am literally
turning my breakthrough is I turn the
page and in this second I start to write
the best chapters of my life you could
decide to do that rule number 49 don't
let your ego hold you back if you meet
people that you think are ego maniacs
that are constantly bragging about
themselves these are the most insecure
people that you know they're the most
fearful people that you know they're the
most scared and they're usually the
least happy and so but I'm gonna say
something to you I want you to consider
as I go through ego today I know you
think well I'm so down on myself how can
I have an ego it's actually the people
that are down on themselves that
actually have their ego materialize and
show up more often than they think and
it's their Eagle that may actually be
holding them back you think wow how
could someone with low self-esteem have
a big
trust me they do and so egos are not
part of people with high self esteem the
people in my life that are the most
self-confident typically don't have big
egos but if you have to wait around for
other people to tell you how your egos
out of control it's too late usually so
we've got to be able to see our ego when
it rears its head be aware of it and it
loses its power over us we can go back
to being our real selves you can't love
yourself if you're not being yourself
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself when ego shows up we're
not ourselves we're not connected to God
there's in other words if you can let go
of your ego you can let God in when you
can let go of your ego you can let your
real confidence in when you let go of
your ego you can go really become who
you were born to be and so oftentimes
this is so important you get you may be
losing right now because of your ego
because of your ego because you're not
feeling good about yourself and rule
number 50 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is change your
identity I think most people back as
their identity and so I'm pretty good at
getting people to change their identity
in other words your identity as the Fox
concept believes values that you hold to
be true about yourself and your life is
gonna be very consistent about your
identity is for the most part the room
right next to Matt I could see it but
you can't there's a thermostat sitting
on the wall in there that thermostat
regulates the temperature of the room
it's not at 75 degrees though right now
I don't put up the doors it's a cold
rainy day here I live right on the ocean
a bunch of cold air is blowing in here
right now but the rooms not gonna cool
down but the external conditions the
rooms going to heat back up 75 degrees
because that thermostat will he beat the
room up to get it to the temperature
it's set up its identity if I open that
door and hot air blew in here which
probably is now that I'm starting to
clock your conditioner will turn on and
cool that room back to 75 degrees it
regulates the temperature your identity
regulates the temperature of your life
no matter what happens the external
conditions can get better and better and
better you may get more money or you're
more fit or you're in a better
relationship but if you don't change
your identity it's if you're a 75 degree
and you're getting 85 90 95 degrees of
results you'll find a way over pretty
short period of time to turn the air
conditioner back out
and get those areas right back to what
your identity is and that's why you'll
see people get ahead and then come back
lose weight and gain it get a great
relationship and lose it make a bunch of
money and get back now I have a special
bonus cup from Edie on how to not hold
yourself back that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what are three goals that you want to
get clear on number two who are three
people that you want to recognize in
your life and say thank you and number
three what difficulty can you turn into
triumph and if you liked this video and
you're gonna take some action after
watching it give me a hash tag believe
down in the comments as well and I hope
everybody listen to this we all have
things in our life listen listen we all
have things in our life were ashamed of
that's right we all I was just thinking
of something the other day I'm real
didn't inches atomic but I can't believe
I did that at one age I'd done something
in a classroom on a test in college you
know nothing I can't believe I did that
like I think we all do things were
ashamed of and what happens is is we
hold our own sins against ourselves and
for the rest of our life and they hold
us back from making progress if you want
to learn how to get rich with Ed my lad
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there biggest
money mistake I made in my life is
investing in things that I don't
understand identity is the governor on
our lives it's the invisible force that
no one understands